[Musique]
il y a 40000 ans durant l'âge de pierre
toute l'Europe était habitée par les
hommes de
Néandertal de fiers
chasseurs à l'exception de même ils
n'ont jamais vu d'êtres
humains soudain des intrus apparaissent
sur leur terrain de chasse ils ont l'air
différents et sont différents des hommes
modernes le début de la fin des
néandertaliia que s'est-il passé entre
ces hommes de l'âge de pierre et nos
ancêtres se sont-ils battus ou
mélanger ce serait-il même reproduit
entre
eux quelle est la part de Néandertal en
nous peu m'importe de savoir qui a
couché avec qui il y a 30 ou 40000 ans
ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent je
m'intéresse à ce qui me concerne
aujourd'hui les Néandertaliens un mythe
dans le monde entier ils étaient forts
ils ont survécu dans un environnement
hostile nos plus proches parents nos
frères de l'air
glaciaire leur vie comme leur mort ont
troublé les
chercheurs les néandertalien ont survécu
300000 ans dans l'Europe de l'air
glaciaire nous n'avons même pas existé
aussi
longtemps la question est pourquoi ontil
disparu les Néandertaliens sont les
seuls autres humains avec lesquels nous
avons part C plante pendant quelques
milliers
d'années apprendre à mieux les connaître
c'est aussi apprendre à nous connaître
nous-même voici une question que je me
pose depuis très
longtemps comment l'omme moderne atil pu
se propager et devenir d'une manière ou
d'une autre la forme dominante de la
biologie humaine dans un lapse de temps
géologiquement assez court sur une
période de 10 ou 20000
ans l'énigme du
n une équipe scientifique internationale
est en train de percer ce mystère às en
Allemagne des chercheurs de l'Institut
Max plan d'anthropologie évolutionniste
sont les premiers à avoir décodé le
génome d'un être humain
disparu pour le généticien suédois c'est
le rêve de toute une vie qui se
réalise en fait nous avons commencé à
travailler sur nanderant
il y a 5 ans le décodage du génome
complet était encore un rêve ça fait 3
ans que nous y travaillons vraiment
depuis un an nous avons les données et
nous les évaluons nous sommes prêts
maintenant nous pouvons oser en
parleranes chercheur passionné est
impliqué depuis le
début jusqu'ici le décodage qui aé le
plus de problm à
l'équipe constamment trouver de
nouvelles méthodes de nouvelles
technologies nous avons dû employer
différentes méthodes et ce n'était pas
toujours facile c'était beaucoup
d'excitation de tension aussi car les
attentes étaient très
hautes la grande question est avons-nous
gardé quelque chose de
Néandertal le musée régional Renant à
bonne cette valise contient les EAU les
plus célèbres au
monde ce sont les joyaux de
l'archéologie
allemande
Ralph Schmitz c'est le gardien de ce
trésor le premier néandertalien retrouvé
dont le nom a été donné à toute une
espèce
[Musique]
d'humain l'archéologue Ralph Schmitz
connaît ses e mieux que
quiconque toute sa vie professionnelle
est centrée dessus
Néandertal cet homme préhistorique qui a
vécu il y a 42000 ans est mort à l'âge
de 40 ans
[Musique]
environ tous ces milliers d'années n'ont
laissé de lui que
[Musique]
16 contiennent-il une clé celle qui
révélera le secret du génô de
[Musique]
Néandertal il est le plus célèbre des
Allemands mais surtout un européen c'est
la seule espèce humaine à s'être
développée en Europe et s'il y a une une
espèce d'humain qui représente l'Europe
et les Européens c'est bien l'homme de
Néandertal cette histoire commence en
1856 dans une carrière près de düseldorf
en
Allemagne c'est une dure journée pour
les
travailleurs forant la pierre creusant
sous la chaleur thoride il tombe sur des
ossems qu'il jette sans réfléchir au bas
du
talu le monde n'aurait jamais entendu
parler de ntal si le propriétaire de la
carrière n'avait pas été
[Musique]
curieux s'agit-il des restes d'un ours
des
[Musique]
cavernes passionné des fossiles le
propriétaire ordonne aux ouvrier de
chercher d'autres
OSM il trouve un crâne comme personne
n'en avait encore jamais vu
étrange qu'est-ce que cela
signifie ces os sont apparus à
Néandertal un coin romantique sur la
rivière du se près de
Metman jusqu'au milieu du 19e siècle la
vallée de Neander était un site naturel
intact et splendide des falaises de CR
escarpé de 50 m de haut bordel à du se
cette gorge étroite et romantique
s'appelait gins elle fut ensuite
rebaptisée Néandertal en l'honneur du
poète Joakim Neander
la vallée de Neander lorsqu'elle était
encore intacte il y a 200 ans le
néandertalien a sûrement été enterré par
sa tribu dans l'une de ses
grottes des hommes préhistoriques ont
trouvé refuge dans une vallée étroite
aux falaisees majestueuse traversé par
la du
seul 40000 ans plus tard cette rivière
coule
toujours un idéal qui a inspiré les
peintes et les
poètes aujourd'hui ce serait une réserve
[Musique]
naturelle mais l'industrialisation est
passée par là et la Chau de la vallée de
Neander est devenue une matière première
très prisée pour la sidérurgie de la
r des milliers de personnes travaillent
dans les
carrières c'est la fin de la vallée de
Neander
personne ne se doute alors de ce que la
découverte des osmans peut
[Musique]
signifier il s'agit bien s du fossile le
plus connu au
monde c'est d'ailleurs ce fossile qui il
y a 150 ans nous a fait prendre
conscience que d'autres espèces humaines
pas tout à fait comme nous av
existéettep d'hom
préhistorique seul Johann Frot un
enseignant comprend immédiatement que
ces eau proviennent d'un homme de l'âge
de pierre les Néandertaliens ont-ils
vraiment existé pour l'élite
scientifique cette question fait l'objet
d'un débat acharné le plus grand
détracteur de cette théorie est rudolp
virchov de Berlin médecin le plus
renommé de son époque et fondateur de la
pathologie il examine les EAU de très
près et tire une conclusion qui sera
lourde de conséquence
il viendrait d'un homme moderne déformé
par la
maladie les os d'un homme malade les
mots de virchov ont ancré le cliché du
néant dertalien stupide jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il est profondément ancré sa
posture voûtée son regard terne ça
m'assue à la main c'est une image
déformé 40000 ans plus tard il est
calomnié l'homme de de Néandertal est un
sauvage poilu plus sing qu'humain brutal
et stupide un bonnet de l'âge de pierre
inférieur à nous en tout
point en
1899 une découverte incroyable en
Croatie fausse encore plus ce tableau
Johannes kraous explore les grottes de
Krapina c'est là qu'on a trouvé le plus
donné en
dertalien dans l'état actuel de nos
connaissances on estime que le site de
crapina comptait entre 60 15 et 80
individu d'après un fragment
dentaire si vous êtesudier le postcanien
l'analyse sera peut-être un peu
différente les fouilles à crapina
fontêtre un soupson
macabre ces néandertalien ne mange
vraiment que de la viande
animale des traces sur les e suggèrent
quelque chose de
terrible certains évoquent le
cannibalisme car cel le
cétait un lieu où pratiqu le
cannibalisme quelle est la raison de ce
comportement cannibal nous n'en savons
rien c'est peut-être la
famineet vous avez aussi des incisions
sur les e il semble donc qu'ils é dép en
quelque
sorte oui plus ou mosp il ne respect pas
les
son
encore canbalisme éta bien
Conn à cause de cette
fragmentation beaucoup d' sont fendu
cassé et
fragmenté dans son bureau du musée
croate d'histoire naturelle à Zagreb
radovi montre à son collègue allem les
preuv soigneusement
conservé l'une des plus grandes
collections de néandertalien au monde
des centaines
d'os certains ont été tellement abîmés
qu'il peut y avoirun seule explication
d'après le
chercheur cette boîte contient beaucoup
d'os des os fendus des os
longitudinau prenez cet os par exemple
certains voil la preuve qu'on a fendu
afin d'en extraire la
Moise c'est la preuve d'un comportement
cannibal à
crapina le long de ces eau ici et là
vous trouverez plusieurs incisions
comme pour enlever du tissu mou il y a
beaucoup d'os comme ça de
longzeau les Néandertaliens de Krapina
étaient-il donc des brutes
cannibales d'autres chercheurs en
doutent ils ont découvert des marques
mystérieuses sur l'un des
crânes une rangée de rayure à intervales
régulier il ne peut s'agir d'une
coïncidence on voit beaucoup beaucoup de
Ré ici
elles sont très serrées et elles sont
très
denses comme si on voulait marquer ce
spécimen ou cette personne qui vient de
mourir c'est un comportement plutôt
surprenant pour Néandertal qu'est-ce
qu'il signifie nous n'en savons rien
mais ça pourrait être un signe de
comportement
symbolique ce doute a
suffit les supposés cannibales de
crapina ont s le nom de t pour de
bon un tel monstre ne convenait pas
comme modèle comme
ancêtre ce devait être une erreur Abe de
l'évolution l'Allemagne naz faisait
régner la loi de la jungle et l'on
disait que l'arien d'acier avait anéanti
l'inférieur
Néandertal un livre scolaire de l'époque
évoque le Néandertal grossier qui était
inférieur à la race
noble
dans l'Allemagne d'Hitler il n'y avait
pas de place pour les
néanderalien les nazis tra Néandertal
avec des Néandertal n'était pas conforme
à l'idéal racial des
nazis nous pouvons nous réjouir que le
spécimen d'origine est été
préservé c'est pour cette raison que les
nazis fir fermer le premier musée
allemand de
neanderta
son successeur moderne situé près du
site de la découverte attire beaucoup de
monde
aujourd'hui Néandertal et sa Massu
ridicule deviennent superstar de l'âge
de
pierre une carrière é
[Musique]
patente l'image que nous avons de nos
plus proches parents a changé
radicalement depuis leur
découverte les chercheurs du monde
entier s'intéressent à eux et à leur
mode de vie
mais surtout qu'avons-nous en
commun les néant dertalien se
déplaçaient rapidement et complètement
debout ils avaient sûrement des yeux
vifs et intelligents ce qui explique
leur survie ils faisaient du feu des
habits et savaient parler c'était des
chasseurs très intelligents de l'air
glaciaire qui vivaient comme le font les
Inuit de nos jours dans
l'Arctique il faut les voir ainsi et
vous serez sur la bonne voie
on sait d' aujourd'hui que Néandertal
était un être social comme nous c'était
un véritable humain un reflet de
[Musique]
nous c'était surtout un habile chasseur
dont le talent mûit au fil des
générations c'était le seul moyen de
survivre dans cet environnement
hostile l'initiation à la chasse était
une leçon très importante dans la vie
d'un
néandertalien ils étaient plus rapides
plus musclés et plus forts que les
hommes modernes aux Jeux Olympiques les
Néandertaliens gagneraient presque
toutes les médailles
d'or cette fascination pour l'homme de
Néandertal touche le monde
entier l'Américain Eric trinus défend
cette thèse depuis des
années nous nous sommes croisés et
reproduits avec
Néandertal j'ai toujours pensé au
processus de l'évolution de l'Homme de
Néandertal et de l'homme moderne et à
leurs interactions lorsqu'ils se sont
croisés quant aux populations quant à la
dynamique complexe des populations et
des flu de
Gênes l'échange de partenaire et la
reproduction entre les population est un
phénomène
naturel et j'ai toujours vu le monde
ainsi
Eric trin est l'un des plus grands
spécialistes de Néandertal au monde lors
de ses fouilles dans le monde entier il
a découvert des squelettes qui pourrai
être issu d'une race mixte de Néandertal
et de
nous mais il lui manquait des preuves le
génie génétique n'était pas encore
développé et c'est ce qui fascine chez
l'homme de Néandertal il est très proche
de nous il est presque nous mais pas
tout à
fait un reflet de nous et en même temps
ce sont d'autres êtres
humains les Néandertaliens maîtrisaient
des techniques raffinées ils obtenaient
des couleurs à partir de diverses
pierres et fabriquai des lances qui
n'avaient rien à envier aux instruments
modernes pour faire du feu ils
extrayaient la Madou d'un champignon qui
pousse sur les
arbres ils étaient surtout d'habiles
artisans de la
pierre ces maîtres ouvriers fabriquaient
des racloirs et des te de lance à
serr il mérite aussi notre respect ils
ont connu une époque très dure dans un
milieu très dangereux avec une
technologie et un développement culturel
global très inférieur au
NES ils ont survécu dans ces conditions
pendant des centaines de
millénaires et on rabaisse souvent les
Néandertaliens on les considère comme
primitifs et
stupide je suis prêt à parier que si
l'un d'entre nous moi incl dev sou
retourner dans la société de Néandertal
et qu'il devait vivre par ses propres
moyens il tiendrait quelques mois au
mieux à l'ipsic les chercheurs de
l'Institut Max Planck analysent
l'alimentation des
néandertalien dans le laboratoire
isotope d'infime particulle d'os de
Néandertal sont
examiné résultat l'alimentation des
hommes préhistoriques était complètement
différente d'
autre car il y a une chose dont ils
avaient besoin plus que
tout la viande beaucoup de
[Musique]
viande on voit né en dertal comme une
sorte de super
prédateur imaginons donc un groupe de
lions vivant dans un territoire et ces
lions ont besoin de beaucoup de proie
ils doivent tuer ils doivent chasser des
animaux pour surviv
et s'ils ne tuent pas assez d'animaux
ils
meurent ce besoin de viande les
animes ils sont toujours en
chasse ils parcourent de longues
distances pour tuer leur lot de
proie ils se contentent parfois de ser
ou de reennes
inoffensifs mais Néandertal ne craint
pas du tout le corps à corps avec des
bêtes plus dangereuses comme l'ours ou
le
mammouth il chasse en groupe et savent
venir à bout d'un
animal et le
[Musique]
tuer cela devait être très
spectaculaire imaginons un groupe de
néandertalien traquant un jeune
rhinoceros
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
difficile à concevoir car nous savons
qu'il n'avait pas beaucoup d'armes pour
tuer à
[Musique]
distance nous savons qu'ils avaient des
LAN en bois des choses comme
ça mais la plupart de ces armes étaient
probablement manié à très courte
distance les proies devaient souvent
être traîné sur des kilomètres jusqu'au
camp les Néandertaliens étaient donc
beaucoup plus musclés que
[Musique]
nous l'animal était dépessé devant la
grotte lorsqu'on dépend de la viande au
détriment d'autres sources
d'alimentation on est
vulnérable les proies peuvent se
raréfier et le climat peut changer
radicalement serait ce raison de leur
disparition l'extinction est une étape
comme une autre de l'histoire
évolutionnaire un jour nous
disparaîtrons aussi il est donc
intéressant de comprendre comment
Néandertal a survécu si
longtemps et pourquoi il a
disparu à l'aide des méthodes les plus
modernes des anthropologues de
l'Institut Max plan de l'psich tente de
percer ce
mystère
la mandibule d'un enfant de 8 ans à
peine a été trouvée dans une grotte en
Belgique c'est une découverte très
précieuse car les fossils de jeunes
néandertalien sont
rares cette mâchoire est la clé d'un
portail temporel vers les chasseurs de
l'âge de
pierre l'œil nu ne suffit
pas pour tirer plus d'information de ce
fossile on le scannait en trois
dimensions on révèle ainsi sa structure
interne les données obtenues ont permis
de créer une chose inédite dans
l'histoire de la science un
néandertalien
virtuel dans la salle de réalité
virtuelle de Leipsic le chercheur
français Jean-Jacques llin observe la
Renaissance numérique de
Néandertal il a inventé cette
technologie qui relie depuis 1900
la préhistoire à la haute
technologie il a ainsi découvert une
différence surprenante entre les humain
et né en
dertal c'est un spécimen très
intéressant et très
important donc il est très important
d'examiner ce genre de
fossile nous avons ici la mandibule d'un
enfant néand
dertalien nous essayons d'évaluer la
vitesse de développement de ces
individus nous avons ici mandibule avec
une deuxième molaire qui a déjà poussé
et une trè molaire qui se développe à
l'intérieur de la
mandibule selon les normes modernes cet
individu devrait avoir environ 12
ans mais si l'on examine un peu la
microstructure interne des dents ces
lignes qui se trouvent dans l'émail sont
un peu comme les anneaux du bois dans un
Tron d'arbre
permett de situer Levelo dans le
temp nous découvrons qu'en fait cet
individu n'avait que 8 ans lorsqu'il est
mort cela signifie que les nétaliens ou
du moins leur dents se développai plus
vite que
nous les Néandertaliens avaient donc une
enfance plus
courte ils avaient beaucoup moins de
temps que nos enfants pour apprendre à
survivre et à
chasser
cependant il pouvait se débrouiller
beaucoup plus
tôt il existe bien sur d'autres différen
entre les humains et l'homme donné en
dertal lorsqu'on regarde leur squelettes
pour la première fois il est évident que
ces deux espèces d'humains sont très
différentes jean-jacqu Hublin compare de
squelettes naraiton un ntalien du
premier
coup si vous croisiez un NAND dertalien
dans la rue ce qui vous semblerait le
plus bizarre serait son visage et sa
tête ils avait une grosse tête et un
grand cerveau comme le
nôtre mais leur visage est très saillant
par rapport à la boîte
cranienne ils avaient un front très
fuyant ce qui constitue une différence
majeure entre l'homme moderne et
[Musique]
Néandertal leurs fortes arcades
sourcilières surmontaient des orbites
larges très
large et tout leur visage est saillant
le menton est
absent bien sûr la vraie question est
qu'est-ce qui nous différencie
là-dedans bien que Néandertal est un
grand cerveau comme les hommes modernes
nous savons qu'il s'est développé
différemment en terme de
vitesse mais aussi en terme de forme et
d'organisation
interne et nous aimerions vraiment
savoir en quoi cela affecte le
fonctionnement du
cerveau les Néandertaliens avaient leurs
habitudes ils se sont bien adaptés à
leur environnement et ont gardé le même
mode de vie pendant des milliers
d'années contrairement à l'homme moderne
qui innove et évolue
on suppose que nandtal vivait en groupe
d'environ 20 personnes la population
totale n'excédait pas les 20000
personnes les derniers néandtalien viv
dans une Europe très différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui durant le dernier
glaciaire il y a 39000 ans le Sud était
couvert d'une forêt dense en Europe
centrale c'était surtout des
au nord la Tundra la Scandinavie était
un semi-désert hostyle couronné d'une
calotque
glaciaire les Néandertaliens peu
nombreux ont peuplé une vaste région de
l'Espagne à la Sibérie
occidentale il laissèrent des traces
partout chaque point indique un site où
des découvertes ont été
faites le plus connu d'entre eux se
trouve à Néandertal en
Allemagne c'est là qu'on a découvert le
tout premier
néandertalien Ralph Schmitz est
déterminé à trouver le reste et fouille
ce site légendaire 150 ans plus
tard la plus grande aventure de sa
carrière ça devient vraiment intéressant
quand on entre dans cette zone la vraie
zone d'excavation se trouve à quelques
mètres sous la surface
elle est protégée par plusieurs
couches
20 m plus haut se trouve la grotte où
les Ossem de Néandertal ont été
trouvés la paroi rocheuse et la grotte
ont été détru pour en extraire la
ch les sédiments de la grotte on d finir
au fond de la vallée au 19e
siècle pour trouver d'autres OS
nandtalien il faut d'abord savoir si la
terre des grottes a été transportée hors
de la vallée en
1856 ou non
une décharge couvre la zone qu'ils
veulent fouiller cependant malgré les
obstacles les travaux à Néandertal
commencent en automne
1997 les chercheurs ont-ils vraiment
choisi le bon
endroit les semaines passent sans
trouvaille
significative les sacs de terre sont
dégagés est amisé à la
main la moindre particule est examinée
c'est un travail
laborieux peu avant la fin des fouilles
une lueur d'espoir apparaît un morceau
d'os provient-il d'un être
humain nous l'avons nettoyé et il est
apparu que ce n'était pas un simple
morceau d'os mais un os Malair
humain en le comparant à un crâne en
plastique d'homme moderne nous avons
constaté que l'OS trouvé était plus
grand nous avons tout de suite compris
que c'était un os malaire de Néandertal
os Paros le squelette est reconstitué
50 autres fragments sont
retrouvés l'os malire nous donne une
idée de ce à quoi pouvait ressembler le
premier
européen
c'est un peu comme un
puzzle les plus importants sont ceux qui
correspondent au squelette
original le tout premier que nous
essayons est un petit fragment du f
gauche si vous regardez ce fur près de
la rotule vous pouvez voir qu'il manque
de petits
morceaux c'est arrivé lorsque les ouvri
de la carrière on frappé les os dans la
terre avec le
B
lorsque les os se sont assemblés c'était
un grand moment dans l'histoire de
l'archéologie j'étais fou d'excitation
c'était si important que j'ai failli
m'évanouir cela prouverait enfin que
nous avons redécouvert le site d'origine
de
Néandertal la clé de l'énigme Néandertal
se trouve à
lapsich une équipe internationale de
chercheurs mené par S au point des
techniques révolutionnaires pour
séquencer l'ADN
ancien nous avons très longtemps
travaillé sur les animaux les ours des
cavernes et les
Mamou ensuite quand nous avons compris
que ça marchait nous avons tenté de
mettre la main sur les e de
Néandertal nous avons finalement obtenu
le soutien de
RAL al a accepté de leur confier un
numérus des échantillons sont
prélevés de la farine est extraite de
l'os puis
examiner contiendra-t-elle assez de
matériel génétique pour craquer le code
génétique de
Néandertal après 40000 ans ce serait un
coup de
chance bien sûr il est important que
l'ADN a été préservée dans cette os
seul 10 % des EAU examiné contiennent
vraiment de
l'ADN les chances sont bonnes car
l'humérus de Néandertal est non
seulement bien conservé mais aussi
étonnamment bien
développé quelle en est la
raison dans sa jeunesse cet homme a subi
une fracture du
coupe pour le restant de sa vie il avait
un usage très limité de son bras
gauche é handicapé en quelque
sorte c'est clairement visible car le
bras gauche est nettement plus mince que
le bras
droit si je les mets côte à côte vous
pouvez les
comparer en tant qu'handicapé il a été
soigné par son groupe pendant 20 ans ça
en dit plus sur Néandertal que le ferait
10 million d'outils en
pierre il n'était pas seulement de
braves chasseurs mais aussi des humains
solidaires les blessures et les
fractures faisaient partie du
quotidien il prenait soin des membres de
la tribu car leur survie dépendait de
chacun de ses
membres il pouvait soigner des blessures
graves autrement dit Néandertal devait
avoir des notions médicales de
base la quête quotidienne de nourriture
était
dangereuse
certains ont comparé ce type de blessure
et de fracture avec celle que peuvent
recevoir les cavaliers de
Rodeo c'est un peu la même chose en
fait il semble donc qu'ils affrontent
physiquement ces
animaux il y a aussi une mortalité assez
haute chez les
adultes c'est donc probablement un des
facteur clé de la démographie
néandtalienne le risque élevé de mourir
jeune
les Néandertaliens avaient peu de chance
d'atteindre l'âge de 40
ans leur dernière demeure était toujours
une
grotte la tribu veillait à ce que le
corps soit protégé des
[Musique]
charognards il couchai les morts sur le
dos ou recroquevill sur le côté dans une
position proche du sommeil
on ne sait pas s'il croyait en des dieux
ou en une vie après la
mort on trouve des sign de rituel
funéire et de C
Mor mais il est impossible d'être plus
précis après 10000
ans une chose est claire
cependant ils étaient humains et il
pleur leur
[Musique]
mort est sontil différents et de quelle
nature sont ces
différences et pour qu'une espèce en
remplace une autre il ne doit pas
nécessairement y avoir une très grande
différence entre ces deux
espèces en décodant le génome de
Néandertal l'équipe de lasich espère
répondre à de nombreuses
[Musique]
questions pourquoi ont-ils disparu et
pourquoi l'homme moderne a-t-il
[Musique]
survécu géné à partir d'un échantillon
d'os du néant dertalien original a
réussi c'est la première fois avec un
humain
disparu à mon avis notre intérêt pour le
génome néandertalien ne concerne pas
Néandertal lui-même mais notre propre
histoire celle de l'homme
moderne car l'homme de Néandertal est
notre plus proche
parent puis les obstacles surgissent le
néandtalien original ne fournit pas
assez de matière pour continuer et
certains os sont
[Musique]
contaminés lorsqu'on travaille avec
l'ADN néandertalien le plus gros
problème est la contamination humaine
humain et Néandertal sont très proches
cela signifie que si je contamine l'ADN
de l'extrédos avec de l'ADN humain je ne
peux plus faire la différence entre les
deux les EAU passent par beaucoup de
mains et chacune y laisse des traces
pour les généticiens ce problème semble
d'abord
[Musique]
insoluble on commence à chercher des Z
non contaminé dans toute
[Musique]
l'Europe nous avons examiné beaucoup
d'os pour n'en trouver que 5 qui avait
assez d'ADN et une contamination assez
basse pour être utile au
projet c'est en Croatie que les
chasseurs de trouvent
bonhe la piste mène à Zagreb à la très
ancienne académie des sciences et des
arts Johannes K est à l'endroit même où
se trouve la clé qui déchiffrera le code
de
Néandertal en sûreté dans une armoire
vitrée ce précieux fossile est resté
plusieurs décennies dans un tiroir
poussireux jusqu'à ce que l'équipe deips
arrive sur
place mené une analyse génétique des os
et trouver de l'ADN de Néandertal dans
beaucoup d'entre eux c'est-à-dire que
nous avons tiré de l'ADN de tous les os
que vous voyez là l'ADN de Néandertal a
donc été préservé pendant des
millénaires nous avons observé ces eau
pour voir s'ils étaient utiles au
projet ils le
sont l'un des eau contient beaucoup
d'informations les chercheurs
l'appellent os
d'or
c'était le plus
exploitable contrairement aux autres eau
il n'est que très légèrement contaminé
par l'ADN
humain dans cette boîte se trouent les
eau qui nous ont donné la clé du génome
donnéand
dertal en route vers le site où les EAU
ont été
découvert il se trouve dans une forêt
dense à 30 km au nord de
Zagreb
accompagné de deux collègues Croates
Johannes kraous visite la grotte de
vindia l'un des sites Néandertaliens les
plus importants en
Europe des générations de Néandertaliens
ont vécu dans cette grotte jusqu'à ce
qu'il
disparaisse c'est un site où l'on trouve
quelquesuns des plus jeunes
néandertalien jamais
découvert sûrement les plus jeunes
Néandertaliens de cette partie de
l'Europe
il vivait à une époque très intéressante
qu'on appelle souvent le changement
bioculturel du Paléolitique moyen au
Paléolithique
supérieur il y a environ 40 à 30000
ans et c'est une époque où des groupes
de personnes à l'anatomie moderne comme
nous vivent dans certaines parties de
l'Europe cette grotte était très
fréquentée par les hommes
préhistoriques 13 couches archéologiques
sontou
la plupart d'entre elles contiennent des
restes de
néandertalien je trouve merveilleux de
penser que des Néandertaliens ont vécu
là dans cette grotte nous nous tenons à
l'endroit même où une autre espèce
d'humain a vécu et trouvé refuge il y a
30000 ans c'est une sensation incroyable
de savoir que Néandertal a certainement
vécu là et a laissé ses eau cependant
ils ont pu être amenés là ils ont pu
être apporté la part des
yenes
gen les chercheurs ont atteint les trait
fonds de la
grotte cela aurait pu arriver
ici les Néandertaliens et les hommes
modernes se sont
rencontrés se sont-ils
mélangés certains pensent que la réponse
se lit dans les
EAU certains pensent que Néandertal
s'est métissé avec certains groupes
d'humains à l'anatomie moderne dès lors
qu'il est arrivé en
Europe mais il a également pu se
métisser bien avant cela avec différents
autres groupes d'êtres
humains donc on se demande si l'on peut
le voir dans la gracilité ou dans
certains traits morphologiques de
viindia c'est une question que l'on se
pose souvent lorsqu'on étudie ces e
fossiles ces e font l'objet de
nombreuses
spéculations
la première rencontre entre l'homme de
Néandertal et l'homme moderne aurait pu
se dérouler aux alentours de
vindia mais les experts en génétique
affirment que cela n'aurait pas pu se
produire en
Croatie si les Néandertaliens et les
hommes modernes s'étaient réellement
mélangés en Europe on trouverait plus
d'ADN chez les Européens d'aujourd'hui
que chez les Asiatiques
d'aujourd'hui et ce n'est pas le cas
on trouve le même ADN néandertalien en
Europe qu'en Asie et qu'en Asie du
Sud-Est à l'ps les EAU DE vindia font
progresser le séquençage du code
génétique
néandertalien grâce à eux les chercheurs
espèrent même pouvoir lire l'intégralité
du
génome pour pouvoir comprendre ce
message qui remonte à l'âge de pierre il
ne suffira pas d'examiner les gènes de
l'homme
préhistorique
pour en savoir plus par exemple sur leur
capacité à parler une comparaison doit
être faite entre notre plus proche
parents disparu Néandertal et notre plus
proche parent
vivant le
chimpanzé les grands singes partagent 99
% de leur gène avec
nous 6 millions d'années d'évolution
nous sépar durant 6 millions d'années
les chimpanzés et les humains ont
accumulé environ 20 millions de
mutations généqu
au total la différence est d'environ 1 %
donc nous sommes en effet très proches
les uns des
autres mais les singes ne parlent pas le
généticien Wolf gangenard effectue des
recherch sur les chimpanzés aux EAU DE
LA
hipsiche lorsqu'un jeêne du langage a
été découvert en Angleterre en 2001ard a
constaté que ce gène n'existait pas chez
les
singes
serait ce vraiment l'un des gemmes du
langage qui a fait une différence si
cruciale entre nous et notre plus proche
parent dans le monde
[Musique]
animal c'est la difficulté que l'on
rencontre lorsqu'on met le doigt sur un
gène nous pensons qu'il s'est passé une
chose très importante dans l'évolution
de l'homme ce qu'on ne peut évidemment
pas vérifier
directement on ne peut pas modifier ce
gène directement chez l'homme ou le
chimpanzé
nous devons donc avoir une sorte d'accès
expérimental par exemple sur l'organisme
modèle le plus important qu'on a à
savoir la souris la souris nous permet
de déterminer ce qui différencie les
diverses variations du gène et en fin de
compte la souris nous ressemble
beaucoup Wolfgang etard veut savoir ce
qui se passe lorsqu'on implante un gène
du langage dans une
souris
il est vrai que la souris ne se met pas
à parler mais elle change et très
[Musique]
distinctement nous allons plus loin et
constatons que ce changement affecte le
cerveau de la souris d'une certaine
manière de sorte que nous pensons
pouvoir l'associer à certaines
caractéristiques
linguistiques et nous l'étudions de plus
près afin de mieux le définir mais nous
avons fait le premier pas il agit d'une
certaine manière sur les neurones et les
zones du cerveau responsable du langage
humain la capacité de parler est une
qualité propre à l'être
humain le modèle de la souris prouve que
le du langage rcouverit jouer rle dans
la
[Musique]
paroleéquipe de exactement le même chez
l'omme
deand en effet la souris Queen un peu
différemment et des changements
surviennent dans son
cerveau ils sont certainement importants
et nous les partageons avec
Néandertal la première partie du code de
Néandertal a été
décryptée c'est une technologie de
pointe qui a rendu possible la percée
finale cette technologie a permis de
déterminer 100 millions de séquences
d'ADN en une seule
fois c'est un million de fois plus que
ce que pouvait cette ancienne machine
nous avons ainsi pu produire autant de
données que nécessair pour décoder le
génome de
néandtal enfin après 1 ans d'études
scientifi l'objectif est
atteint le génome de Néandertal est
décodé le résultat est
[Musique]
sensationnel ils se sont un peu mélangé
et il y a un peu de Néandertal en
nous mais
combien pour trouver la réponse les
chercheurs étudient aussi l'homme
moderne il comparent le gène Néandertal
avec un génotype d'homme et de femmes
tous issus de C régions différentes du
monde le résultat est à nouveau
surprenant la répartition de l'héritage
néandertalien varie dans le monde
[Musique]
entier le plus étonnant avec ces
résultats c'est qu'on trouve cette
petite
chez les Européens et les asiatiques
mais pas chez les
Africains il semble que les Européens et
les Asiatiques quelque chose en commun
une petite partie du génome
néandertalien c'est une révolution
jusqu'alors nous pensions être
totalement différent des
néandalien le grand
mystère comment les Néandertaliens
ont-ils pu contribuer à des régions du
monde qui n'ont jamais été habité par
Néandertal
la théorie la plus probable est que cela
s'est produit très tôt ce mélange avec
Néandertal les ancêtres Néandertaliens
de Croatie que nous avons
étudié ça a probablement eu lieu au
Moyen-Orient tout commence en Afrique il
y a 500000 ans les premiers hinidés se
séparent en plusieurs lignes les
ancêtres de l'homme à l'anatomie moderne
et les ancêtres de l'homme de
Néandertal les premiers hommes de
Néandertal migrent s'installent à l'est
et se répandent dans toute
l'Europe environ 100000 à 50000 ans
avant notre ère l'homme moderne migre
aussi d'Afrique et se reproduit avec
l'homme de
Néandertal dans leur marche triomphale à
travers le monde ils emportent une toute
petite part d'ADN néandertalien dans
leur bagage
génétique il le répandent dans des
régions jamais habité par l'homme de
Néandertal en résumé les Néandertaliens
sont bien nos ancêtres nous sommes une
famille Néandertal c'est nous et je
trouve merveilleux qu'il reste quelque
chose de ces fascinants chasseurs de
l'air
glaciire 28000 ans avant notre ère
l'homme de Néandertal disparaî les
humains qui portent leurs gèes sont
retournés en
Afrique ce n'est qu' au sud du Sahara
qu'on ne trouve plus d'ADN né en
dertalien j'aime à penser que le grand
public serait heureux de savoir que nous
avons un peu de Lomme de Néandertal en
nous c'était des durs c'était des
humains durables ils vivaient dans des
conditions très res ils ont survécu des
centaines de
millénaires je serais très fier de
savoir que j'ai des Néandertaliens parmi
mes
ancêtres nous avons beaucoup en commun
avec
Néandertal par exemple des fouilles
menées dans toute l'Europe ont révélé
que comme nous les hommes préhistoriques
se maquillaient avec des couleurs à base
d'argile et pourtant ils étaient
différents en quoi sommes-nous
différents qu'est-ce qui nous rend si
unique par exemple pourquoi les
Néandertaliens ne produisaient-il pas
d'art je ne peux toujours pas expliquer
pourquoi Néandertal nous égale en tout
hormi le fait qu'il ne produisait pas
d'art
l'homme moderne était le premier à
introduire l'Art en Europe il y a 40000
ans cette différence peut-elle être
identifiée
génétiquement dans une salle blanche
Johannes k r une séquence de GES de
Néandertal visible à l'il
humain en déchiffrant le code de
Néandertal les chercheurs espèrent
aujourd'hui pouvoir découvrir les tout
derniers secrets de l'humanité
on peut aller au-delà des flux de gèes
et de la reproduction des un et des
autres durant
le nous pouvons nous interroger sur la
biologie sur les comportements sur
l'adaptation cela nous permettra
peut-être de savoir ce qui a fait que ce
modèle dans la biologie humaine moderne
ce modèle biologique de l'homme moderne
s'est avéré le plus
efficace
l'homme moderne ne réussit pas
simplement parce qu'il sait mieux
communiquer pendant des millénaires
Néandertal n'a presque pas
changé mais nous sommes flexibles nous
pouvons deviner ce que pense quelqu'un
nous pouvons penser en symbole mais nous
sommes aussi une espèce agressive et
nous ne laissons pas de place aux autres
espèces ni aux autres
humains le code de Néandertal nous
procure la clé des questions les plus
importantes en ce qui nous concerne
comparer et apprendre pourrait même
servir à comprendre et affronter les
défis de l'avenir de
l'humanité le vrai mystère est la raison
pour laquelle une espèce la nôtre a
temps
perduré pourquoi est-elle si
envahissante comment a-t-elle pu
recouvrir toute la planète et être si
prospère si
féconde néandertalien étaient très
talentueux à bien des égards ils
vécurent des millénaires dans des
conditions très rudes malgré les
changement climatiqu et les périodes
glaciaires tenant tête à la nature
jusqu'à ce qu'un événement inattendu les
prenne de
[Musique]
cours penser qu'une cause naturelle
aurait conduit à l'extinction de l'Homme
de Néandertal au moment même où l'homme
moderne s'installait en Europe après 20
ou 30 centaines de milliers d'années
vous savez de haut et de bas dans la
population ce serait une coincidence
incroyable que cela se produise au
moment de l'arrivée de l'homme
moderne l'arrivée de l'homme moderne sur
la terre de l'Homme de Néandertal il y a
40000 ans a marqué le début de la
fin il s'empare des terrains de chasse
de
Néandertal ils se reproduisent beaucoup
plus
vite le nombre d'hommes préhistoriques
diminue ils sont repoussés aux
frontières de leur terre
d'origine leur culture est perdue à
jamais leur
savoir-faire leurs talent de
chasseur leur solidarité de tribu est
ruiné mais aujourd'hui nous en savons
plus que jamais sur nos frères dis
[Musique]
ce tableau ce puzzle de Néandertal gagne
de plus en plus en
couleur ils continueront à nous fournir
de la matière à étudier pendant au moins
50 VO 100
ans l'homme de Néandertal a disparu il y
a près de 30000
ans nous seuls homme modne dominons
aujourd'hui la
planète
mais une petite part de Néandertal a
survécu en chacun de nous jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
[Musique]